foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist I
got with me my co-host Chuck Nice Jeff
hey what's happening all right it was
good to have you there man especially
when we have Cosmic queries oh fan
favorites oh yeah fan favorite we love
them uh you get to ask a question with
sort of entry-level participation in our
patreon program just five dollars a
month that we collected them and you
know in advance what you're asking about
because today's topics
involve physics and philosophy
people love just talking about stuff for
which there is no answer of course you
know why because it makes them feel like
they have a stake and a say and it's
like because nobody has the answers yeah
nobody has the answer so I'm just as
right as you are right like no you're
not you're still an idiot okay see I
have a PhD in philosophy and physics I
have what's called an informed opinion
you on the other hand went on the
internet saw somebody on Joe Rogan's
show say something about something else
and now you think you're an expert shut
up shut up
right okay that's the end of our show
well we we we're bringing into this uh
an old friend and colleague Sean Carroll
Sean welcome to StarTalk hey thanks for
having me on Neil welcome back to Stark
talk I see I should say this is you've
been on at least four or five times uh
you are one of the world's experts on
not only physics being a physicist but
you're also that subcategory of
physicist who cares about philosophy and
have engaged philosophers on the
frontier of our understanding of physics
so it's great to have you for this
Cosmic queries and dare I say we crafted
this Cosmic queries around your
expertise so I don't have to give you
nothing but the correct true answers so
okay otherwise chuckle get on your case
don't don't make me go on another
diatribe
so you're the Homewood professor of
natural philosophy at the Johns Hopkins
University right there in Baltimore and
you have a joint appointment at the
Santa Fe Institute now that Institute
everything I know about it those are
deep thinkers about things that it's
like what like you twist your head like
a dog hearing a high pitch it's like
what and you're the fractal faculty at
the Santa Fe Institute and your
expertise in quantum physics space time
cosmology love it emergence
um entropy Dark Matter Dark Energy
symmetry origins of the Universe
um and perhaps most people who know you
know you through your mindscape podcast
so always good stuff happening there
those things that make you uh tilt your
head and scrunch up your eyes like
that's my Lane that's what I do that's
you
with that oh I'm gonna keep them in it
okay so I say this lovingly and crazily
stay in your lane okay
and full of crazy people but I'm I'm in
it so tell me what is uh First Natural
philosophy I'd last saw that term with
you know 17th 18th century
philosophers natural philosophy was the
then term for what today we would call
physics right because political
philosophy and religious natural
philosophy was physics so what why isn't
that just physics professor there's a
joke in philosophy circles that once an
area of philosophy starts making
progress it gets spun off to a
completely different field so it never
looks like philosophy actually makes
progress but you're right Newton Galileo
those folks would have called themselves
philosophers the idea of a physicist
hadn't been invented yet but what
happens is that Academia loves to
categorize and Silo people so they
invent a physics department and a
philosophy department and they examine
what questions you could ask and they
decide which is which but what that does
is that it means that all the in-between
stuff because it's really a Continuum
here not a interstitial ideas and things
those just get lost and we're at a point
in physics right now where questions
like you know what is an observer what
is infinity why is the past different
from the future what is emergence like
these are physics questions but it
clearly was different from all other
nights
so you are there to clean up the pieces
is what you're saying well I'm actually
there to understand the Universe I think
that the common thing uh within natural
philosophy is we're not studying the
process of science or anything like that
we're studying nature we're studying
reality but there's a way of doing it
that it's kind of foundational that you
know takes a step back look physicists
plus their hearts you've met physicists
Neil I know this uh and ask them by the
way Chuck anytime someone prefaces
something by bless their heart bless
your heart they're about to insult them
in some nothing nothing good ever you
know it's just in the same sentence as
bless their hearts especially if you're
an old white lady from the south you
know what I mean they said oh bless her
heart she's just a little that's
all
Sarah you know it's true that's how it
goes okay I started a book by saying uh
you do not need a PhD in theoretical
physicists in physics to be afraid of
quantum mechanics but it doesn't hurt
and physicists don't want to dig into
the deepest questions about quantum
mechanics they want to calculate their
differential equations they show up and
calculate you shut up and calculated and
that's the opposite of what I like to do
myself so the Philosopher's uh humor me
on that so just to be just to make sure
all our audience is on the same page
quantum mechanics is
is amazingly successful at predicting
and and and and
describing reality
but that reality defies all our common
sense
and you reach a point where you just say
okay I'll just live with that and
continue to calculate and Sean you're
telling me you're not satisfied with
that you want to understand
crazy Quantum phenomena on some level
where we can sit down and say okay now I
understand it is that what's driving you
yeah absolutely just like it drove
professors Einstein and Schrödinger back
in the day but there was this uh
consensus that developed in the 1920s
and 30s by physicists where like you say
we have some equations we can solve them
we can calculate them we can make
predictions and book beautiful Exquisite
agreement between the calculations and
the predictions without knowing what's
going on without freeing right actually
happening in the world and there's a
whole bunch of physicists who will say
oh no understanding what is actually
happening in the world that's not my job
I'm just here to make predictions I
strongly feel that's not right I'm here
to help understand what is going on
right so you you're the show your work
part of this whole equation explain your
work show it unhide anything no scene
yeah it's okay to come up with the
answers but we got to know how we got
there absolutely yeah so Sean what's
been in all the buzz in recent years is
a quantum entanglement all right and
let me offer my best explanation and you
correct it and then but then give me
your understanding of it all right you
can create two particles simultaneously
that have sort of complementary
properties Quantum properties to them
and they can separate and they know
about each other there I use the word no
they they know about each other's
existence
and and the moment you make a
measurement of one of them the other
particles properties manifest to whoever
is observing them and they manifest
instantly
transcending the speed of light
and so we know that happens but Sean
you're going to tell me that you
understand it or will you not
well I think that we have multiple
competing ways to understand it we have
not agreed on the correct way my way is
like I said Chuck in the bar you just
have the beer and nobody agrees right
that's the difference but like like you
said we can make the prediction to
Exquisite accuracy people tested the
prediction they won the Nobel Prize for
it last year that was what the physics
Nobel Prize was given for and by the way
the whole reason we know and care about
entanglement was because Einstein in
1935 was trying very hard to figure out
what really is going on right and he
didn't quite succeed he didn't get the
answer there but it's that drive to
understand that led here and ultimately
what we can say I think with some
confidence is that what the world is is
not a bunch of separate particles doing
their own thing it looks like a bunch of
separate particles under certain very
clear circumstances but in other
circumstances like this entanglement
business it doesn't it's more holistic
than that so people like me who are
Advocates of the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics we
have a very simple straightforward way
of talking about entanglement but
there's other people out there who talk
about it differently and you know that's
great that's what Academia and
intellectual curiosity is all about
remind us of the many worlds hypothesis
because I think that's now 100 years old
right we're we're on the Centennial
decade of the major discoveries of
quantum physics the 1920s so if you can
just remind us what the many worlds I
think it was once explained to me then I
said
what are you smoking I think that's for
sure that's what I said tell us when we
teach undergraduates quantum mechanics
we say that a Quantum system has two
different ways of evolving there's one
way it can evolve when you're not
looking at it and that's what
Schrodinger and Heisenberg and their
friends figured out back in the day well
just to be clear I just to be precise I
know how you're using the word evolve
but to a biologist the word evolve means
something completely different so you
mean it unfolds yeah the events unfold
yeah it's it changes it has its Dynamics
whatever it's doing whatever its
behavior is but then there's a whole
nother way that we need to describe that
behavior when we make a measurement when
we observe the system famously in
quantum mechanics you can't predict
deterministically precisely with 100
confidence what answer you're going to
get you can predict a probability
distribution over different possible
answers so the Einstein said God does
not play dice that's what Einstein said
yes and the universe or so it kind of
looks like
you are playing dice I'm just saying I'm
just
and by the way what a uh what a
presumptuous statement on Einstein's
behalf I mean who knows Sean didn't
Niels Bohr say I stopped telling God
what to do exactly I mean who's to say
that God's not down to one knee going
popping these a new pair of shoes you
don't know that you don't know that so
it wasn't me it was more somebody said
it to Einstein who was it I think I
think it was Niels boy I think the
better advice would be like don't play
dice against God you're not going to win
if that's yeah okay there you go that
that makes sense so what is this going
on with this weird thing you don't
expect measurements observations looking
at things to be part of the fundamental
nature of reality right you know it
never was before quantum mechanics came
along so you can ask yourself what if
like all that was unnecessary this whole
idea that we need a separate rule for
what happens when we measure something
what if you just erase that from the
rules of quantum mechanics and the
answer is that what do you find is that
every possible measurement outcome comes
true but in a different world in a
different part of the overall Quantum
Universe you get parallel worlds where
different measurement outcomes are true
that's when I asked what the guy was
smoking wow
now wait so that these different worlds
are in the same
realm is that the case or are we talking
about completely different
um unfoldings that create completely
different scenarios that make the whole
thing work or another way to ask that do
you have access to these other worlds
there you go thank you you have iPhone
you can download an app called Universe
splitter
and if you're ever stuck on what
decision to make you know should I have
a hamburger should I have pizza for
dinner tonight or whatever ask the
universe splitter and we'll come back
with an answer and you can be guaranteed
that there's a whole nother Universe
which you can never interact with or
talk to in which you do the opposite
thing it's split in that instant right
in that instant yes yeah at the decision
instance okay okay it's a physical
Quantum process but and and that's
because of the entanglement because they
couldn't exist simultaneously they have
to exist in those positions at the time
of the decision so that when one does it
the other does the opposite or when one
does something so there's a there's an
action and there's a reaction but there
can't be action action it has to be so
that they're existing and then reacting
differently
Sean Chuck is about to blow a gasket and
no because you're freaking me out man
you are free get me out this is not
anything that we uh bump into in our
everyday lives if it doesn't make you a
little bit uncomfortable you're not
taking it seriously okay all right I am
wow all right sure let's get to the
questions okay man
this is already good stuff boy I'll tell
you right I'm so mad I didn't
have an edible before this show
I really should have taken the gummy
before this one dog gone again these are
from our patreon supporters thank you
all for what you do for us it allows us
to experiment and bring new and creative
content to you that's yet to be proven
to be commercially viable so that's what
would that's what's going on here all
right Chuck you got your your iPad there
all right I do so here we go hi I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I'm Lindsay Nix
Walker senior producer of Star Talk and
Neil and I just co-authored a brand new
StarTalk book coming out September 12th
yeah this is the third in a series of
collaborations with National Geographic
books and this one is titled to infinity
and beyond and it's available for
pre-order from the StarTalk website
startalkmedia.com
books if you pre-order it you get to
gain access to a live stream that
Lindsay Walker and I will do from this
office and you have the occasion to
submit questions that we will answer
that's right if you pre-order from
startalkmedia.com books we'll answer
your questions about the book The
Universe Neil's favorite kind of cheese
whatever you want
all right so we'll see you there and
we'll see you then
this is from Psy uh says hello Dr Tyson
Dr Carol Dr haha uh first time patreon
member I know right first time patreon
remember here a huge huge fan uh I am
Sai anurag
U
from India uh Chuck if you get my name
right I swear to God I will double my
patreon membership
exactly
yeah well I I guess you have no you're
in no danger there are you yeah I think
he's gonna have it after what you just
did to his name but all right
that was funny uh my question pertains
to Dr Carroll's research which says that
the universe is infinitely old and big
bang is just one of many events
resulting from Quantum fluctuations of a
vacuum energy in a cold this litter
desitter space please throw some light
on what kind of space is this how can I
visualize it better in order to
understand it more fully ooh
good very good I love it you know
hanging out on the wrong street corners
I don't know where they where they
picked these things up but yes this is
all driven by the very famous philosophy
question why is the past different from
the future why is there an arrow of time
because the fundamental laws of physics
have no Arrow of time in them the answer
is entropy and the second law of
Thermodynamics the universe used to be
more organized lower in entropy the
whole history of the universe is just
entropy increasing disorder and Chaos
developing all around we're all gonna
die that's the it's not your fault
necessarily but you're contributing to
the disorder and Chaos all around us and
that started about 14 billion years ago
near the Big Bang at the moment of the
beginning of the universe our universe
was exquisitely orderly it doesn't
necessarily look that way but you run
through the numbers and it's true why
why is that true why was the early
universe so orderly and so uh I've long
wondered about this and I wrote a paper
years ago now with uh uh a woman who's a
graduate student of mine at the time
Jennifer Chen where we proposed that the
Big Bang was not the beginning of our
universe other people proposed that in
different contexts but we made the case
that you don't need a fine-tuned special
organized low entropy beginning of the
universe the universe can be Eternal it
can last forever but what happens is it
empties out just like our universe is
doing a universe can be completely empty
the future of ours will be but it still
won't be perfectly quiet there are still
Quantum fluctuations that can lead to
whole new universes coming into
existence and as that happens they all
start in low entropy conditions and the
entropy uh grows and gives that little
part of the universe a narrow of time
and the fun part is the far far past the
same thing happens but in the other
direction so there's sort of a symmetric
shape to the universe where the future
is a story of more and more universes
being rated and the arrow of time
pointing in that direction the past is
the story of more and more universes
being created with people in them who
think that we are in their past
I I'm gonna tell you right now uh
if if Psy
understands what the hell you just said
and they need to be the co-host of this
show
so Sean what you're saying is there's
some symmetric point
among these universes and these time
continua where
in One Direction
we're entropy
increases
but in principle there's a whole other
Realm
where entropy decreases
from our point of view from the people
living in it they will always see
entropy increasing because we always
Define the past as the direction in
which entropy was lower so it's a big U
shape that is perfectly significant now
so now that so we're in their past
because they're looking at us and seeing
a decreasing entropy which is and which
is indicative of traveling backwards
because we're moving towards a more
ordered universe but we cannot be moving
towards a more ordered Universe if we're
moving into the future because we are
always moving towards entropy so if you
are observing that then you are in my I
am in your past so because you're
looking at me going towards order
Chuck gets it we're done yeah man
[Laughter]
Chuck you're blowing out the volume
level one that's insane okay wait so so
Sean before we get to the next question
what
um these are ideas
is there any way to experimentally
verify any of this well we're trying but
the short answer is we don't know yet we
don't have uh it's not like a no just
say it
oh it was very much not a no oh okay but
all the words deal these all the words
matter here okay yeah and this but this
is a more a broader idea right um there
are plenty of tentative preliminary
scientific ideas which are too ill yet
I'm with you predictions Einstein's
um gravitational waves Einstein's
gravitational Rings yeah I'll give you
that we'll get there we will get there
send money we'll we'll do it just trust
us yeah in your lifetimes
yeah every time it's getting shorter
every year so I don't know
yeah your life expectancy is dropping
every year yeah yeah all right Chuck
what else are you at all right let's go
on to Doug Sherman Doug Sherman says hi
Neil hi Sean Lord nice uh the Doug this
is Doug from Frisco Texas all right all
right Doug says I thoroughly enjoyed
Sean's debate on God and cosmology
against William Lane Craig although I'm
still trying to get my head around
everything Sean explained once one
amongst many arguments I found
interesting was Sean's rebuttal against
Mr Craig's technological argument that
the finely tuned Universe was evidence
for the existence of God I don't recall
the specifics but I believe Sean stated
that in some models the probability of a
finely tuned Universe approaches one and
then it's oh man
he he must have cut and paste because it
drops out then he so he he he the finely
tuned Universe approaches then he says
could Sean once again go through the
perspective of the fine-tuned argument I
also reject the technological argument
but for more simplistic reasons than my
flawed Brink can rationalize so just for
context William link Craig is a
proponent of
um basically a god-created universe and
he's not the Bible thumping person in
such a conversation as others might be
he's trying to stay grounded in the
natural world taking you to a precipice
where you say Okay God must be there so
I I'm pretty sure Sean wouldn't debate
just anybody on that subject so William
Lane Craig has some some uh debating
respectability in that regard do they
characterize that you're not going to
throw down with Pat Robertson
or Jimmy Swaggart that's right
it's not on the debate stage no okay I
do think that the what is called the
fine-tuning argument did I characterize
your your opponent accurately would you
say yeah that's fine
um but the the fine-tuning argument for
the existence of God is what I think is
the best argument for the existence of
God I also think it's a terrible
argument but still it's the best of the
ones that they have so I've read when
they refer to it and the idea is that
you look around the world the world in
which we live the universe we find
ourselves in and you say there are
features of this universe that need to
be the way they are in order for life to
exist
if they were different life couldn't
exist but it they easily could have been
different right that the things like the
amount of energy in empty space could
have been so large that it would rip
planets apart before they ever formed
but we seem to have gotten lucky we seem
to find ourselves in a universe that
allows for our existence and so the
argument is I know why it's because God
did it because God created a universe in
which that's possible a very common
counter argument is well it also could
just be a Multiverse right there could
be many different parts of the universe
and we just are finding ourselves in the
hospitable one but there's two things
you're not in all the others to have
this conversation right so they help
play an explanatory role in in
accounting for why our universe looks so
fine-tuned so two things going on here
one is the proponents of this argument
tend to exaggerate the degree of
fine-tuning that they need and that's
what the questioner is referring to
there's certain things that William Lane
Craig and others say oh that I just
don't get it that's so fine-tuned but
you can raise your hand and say actually
physics has completely explained that
one now we don't need to go beyond the
realm of physics to account for that so
but in other ways it still looks
fine-tuned and and my favorite rejoinder
is actually this is a great argument for
the non-existence of God because if God
existed and God created life God is not
beholden to the local laws of physics
God can create life however God wants to
because he's God God can do anything you
don't need the physical conditions to
allow for the existence of Life unless
God does not exist
all right now let me let me let me just
ask a question here because I uh just
just to further clarify by what if
uh instead of needing the laws of
physics the laws themselves are a
reflection of what God has done so it's
not necessarily that the that the laws
are needed it's that the laws exist
because they just happen to be a
byproduct of the creation itself
that is completely possible and Neil
will raise us in here and say how do we
observationally test that hypothesis
okay listen I'm 100 with with I'm on
board with that okay good I just wanted
to make sure that that could that that
could be an argument to be here it
smells like Spinoza's God right which is
that the whatever God is to you the laws
of physics are the manifestation of it
oh so I'm not that smart somebody
already thought of my question could
have been Chuck's argument but
nice is god
um but look for the last 500 years as
science has done more and more to
explain why the universe is the way it
is the role for God as an explanatory
move has gone away has diminished right
and so you are continues to do so yes
and so you're left with if you want to
believe in God and there's plenty of
very very smart people who do they they
tend not to rely on God to account for
the things that we observe in the
natural world what is called natural
theology as opposed to Natural
philosophy natural theology is not so
popular anymore
gotcha all right fascinating stuff all
right Chuck keep going we've only gone
through two or three questions let's see
if we can speed up okay we just have to
have Sean back that's all this stuff is
too good we can't rush we cannot rush
through this
at one point get a double wide episode
with him maybe yeah well yeah yeah
absolutely all right this is Tom B
Knight hello I'm a patreon supporter of
both Star Talk and mindscape we're great
to see Sean on the show uh do voids in
the cosmic web like the iridonis uh
supervoid violate the cosmological
principle what could be the cause of
these structures thank you for your
service okay good one every dinosaur is
a constellation I think it's a waterfall
or is it has something to do with water
my memory serves but anyhow uh Sean what
you got there this is a great question
but there's a lot going on here I'm
going to try to keep it brief here you
know there's something called the
cosmological principle that says that if
you squint and look at the Universe on
very large scales everything looks the
same everywhere right the same number of
galaxies and whatever it's a Dopey thing
to call a prince simple because it's not
a principle it's just a fact that you
see about the universe it could easily
have been otherwise especially because
it's not exactly true and that's what
the question is getting at there are
places in the universe where matter is
very dense there's places where it's
very empty and so forth the way that
modern cosmologists think about this
question is to say the early Universe it
was even smoother than it is now it was
very very smooth there was only a
difference in one part in a hundred
thousand as you went from place to place
number one why was it not perfectly
smooth but number two why was it pretty
darn smooth and number three how did it
evolve using the word evolve again from
that condition 100 000 years after the
big bang to our conditions now the last
one how it evolved is the one we have
the best handle on it was gravity doing
the work gravity turns up the contrast
knob on the universe so if you have a
slightly emptier region it empties out
you have a slightly heavier region it
collects matter onto it and so we went
from very faint ripples if you look at
the cosmic background radiation to these
very Vivid voids and Galaxy clusters
that we see today we still don't know
where those first ripples came from
inflationary cosmology is a is a
favorite thing to talk about but that's
a whole nother episode
wow I like the way you said that you we
this we observe these fluctuations about
apart in a hundred thousand and you say
well how come it's not perfectly smooth
how come it's one part in a hundred
thousand and how come it's not anywhere
near that today that's a fun way to
think about that problem because it's
easy to say oh here's the answer and
then move on but wait a minute why isn't
it something else yeah right and not
enough of that goes on I think well it's
it's a Once Again a reflection of the
fact that the early Universe had low
entropy because gravity was so strong in
the early universe
uh more common generic random
configuration would have been wild
fluctuations like black holes here and
empty space there and so the fact that
it was so smooth does kind of demand an
explanation and we're not sure what the
explanation is
all right keep this going Chuck uh this
is Malcolm Marfan and Malcolm says hello
Dr Tyson Dr Carol and Chuck maybe okay
um
okay I love these people they love you
Chuck no matter what they call you I
know nobody I know
[Laughter]
well Malcolm marfon here all the way
from Trinidad and Tobago and this is
nice he says Dr Carol I came across your
2018 paper why is there something rather
than nothing and thought wow this guy's
really dedicated to a lot of brain power
to the concept of nothing now since
you've clearly become an expert in
nothingness can you shed some light on
the various layers of nothing uh
specifically how do these layers of void
stand apart and how are they intertwined
with the head-spinning Realms of
cosmology and quantum mechanics P.S can
I get a philosophy or Physics degree
with nothing from with nothing for my
thesis
I think our questioner missed the point
of the title of my paper which is that
there is something like you know we can
contemplate that there wouldn't have
been anything and there's just nothing
but what I say in the paper is
can we really contemplate that I mean I
think that we have this informal
training from our everyday lives right
where we have boxes with things in them
and boxes with nothing in them and so we
think that there's an option there can
be things that there could be nothings
but when the it comes to the universe it
is not at all obvious that there is an
alternative to the universe existing
what does it even mean for nothing to
exist how does nothingness even exist I
mean that's kind of what I'm getting at
in the paper which is that it's not at
all clear that the reason why the
university exists is the kind of thing
that has an answer to a why question uh
maybe we maybe we just have to accept it
as a brute fact and be lucky about it so
I do think this stuff is fun to talk
about but I I don't think that uh it is
nearly as down to earth and simple and
physical as certain physicists to like
to talk about this uh make it out to be
it's a it's a fun mentally a philosophy
question wait but Sean uh if there were
no quantum physics in principle you
could talk about space as having no
particles and none of these virtual
particles that quantum physics forces
into it you just say remove the atoms
and all known particles
that's as pretty good and nothing as
anyone would hope to describe isn't it
no it's something it's space it has
because you have a word for it okay you
you call the empty space space and I
call the empty space nothing aren't we
just semantically differing there not
fundamentally differing is empty space
three-dimensional
I don't know
you just don't want to answer it because
okay so let's say let's say it's
three-dimensional and and exists on a
time continuum sure it's oh it has a
property then it's not nothingness it is
there's a way it could have been
different you invoke a way to measure
stuff in it I wouldn't call that an
inherent property of the empty space
it's it's different than
four-dimensional empty space okay so how
about this how about this okay uh again
one of the reasons why I don't like
arguing with philosophers because
ultimately it comes down to how you're
defining the words that you're using in
your sentence in so many of those
arguments so let me just say if we
Define something versus nothing
as something is there's a thing there
and I take everything out so that as
Chuck said there's as you said there is
no thing nothing there then that's
nothing
okay now we're now you're saying there's
a grid system there that we can invoke
or it's inherent so that's a thing okay
so now I add to my inventory of a thing
particles plus grid systems okay fine
then that's there no so now we have to
ask can we take away the grid what I
think is a more interesting question is
do the laws of physics apply in that
volume
and therefore can't be entirely nothing
because laws of physics apply even
though there's nothing there to manifest
them ooh now you're getting deep so I
like it because you're invoking not what
the system is but counter factual
properties of what would happen to the
system if you changed it a little bit
which is fine it's a fine thing to do
look you're absolutely right that there
is no pre-existing definition of the
word nothing to which we're referring
here you could have different ideas I
think that the deepest level of this
question is why is there a universe at
all versus complete non-existence not
even space I mean even you had to
preface your question by saying like
imagine there was no quantum mechanics
and for that matter secretly imagine
there's no general relativity either
because okay yeah you're throwing away
all of known physics to even ask your
question but of course within known
physics you can ask plenty of questions
about why isn't space empty why is space
three-dimensional those are perfectly
good physics questions it's a little bit
different than the question of why
there's a universe at all you can ask
the post them separately it's not a
right or wrong thing to ask right yeah
all right well that's all right cool
what a great question yeah yeah because
when someone says why is there something
rather than nothing and I look out in
the universe which is mostly nothing I
say there's a lot of nothing in the
universe I just
so whatever something we have that's is
side by side with a lot of nothing and
until you start invoking other
definitions for what nothing can be so
that's all that's my only point there
well there you have it Malcolm uh we
have discussed your question and we have
uh we have achieved nothing
okay
[Laughter]
all right all right keep it going this
is Javier Ortega who says hi you guys
are just the best greetings from my
artificial limbs development lab in
Panama just a quick question that will
not let me sleep till to the speed of
light we can only see the past while
looking into distances of the cosmos how
do we know we are in the quote unquote
real present
we sense everything with delay even
short distances also there's a delay
between our census and our brain are we
sure that we perceive now as now maybe
it's just something relative to us like
movement maybe we are five hours in the
past or 200 million light years in the
past According to some other arbitrary
timeline or other alien beings that
could be TR that could travel absolutely
everybody's been smoking before they
said let me tell you man I told you I
told you
but he says I hope you read this message
from the past
please keep looking up he makes an
interesting point that
what is what is the present even mean
if everything we do to interact with the
world has some kind of time delay
yeah I'd like that idea of the brain or
understanding our senses our that's true
our
uh you know my hand is not as it is it
as it was a billionth of a second ago so
what does it even mean to talk about the
present yeah there's a scientist here
and a philosophy answer here I'll give
you the science answer because it's
quite good uh our brain does not
perceive the present our brain puts
together a picture of the world that is
on a slight time delay like our brain
wants to be able to bleep out things
that it doesn't like if you watch
someone dribble a basketball and they're
right next to you you will see the
basketball hit the ground and you will
hear the thump of the basketball against
the ground and they coincide they go
along with each other if that person
walks away still true you see and hear
the same thing at the same time even
though the light gets to you much
quicker than the sound and what happens
is if they keep walking away
suddenly they will go out of sync the
vision of the basketball hitting the
ground and the sound of it because that
happens suddenly so your brain has
correcting for it holy because your
brain corrects for it as long as it's
near enough your brain says this is all
now and you can even measure how much it
is it depends on what sense you're
talking about and what perception but
roughly think about 40 or 50
milliseconds of time is a little window
in which your brain collects things and
says I'm going to put this together into
a picture of well millisecond is a
thousandth of a second so forty to fifty
thousandths of a second would be like
five hundredths of a second there you go
good method excellent yes right so what
you're saying is there's a point where
the brain just gives up
uh recreating the present and said I
can't compensate for this it's too hard
it's too much I can't do no more so you
do
deal with it
oh God
you can't take it
no
so so so this is an experimental result
Sean you know look as as I'm sure you
are already know Neuroscience biology
psychology that's a whole Frontier right
there they like it way harder than
physics or astronomy way harder way
harder
oh yeah okay I did not know this so uh
interesting so the brain constructs a
present so that we can help make sense
of the world in our own moment that we
make decisions it's actually doing that
with everything all the time your brain
because there's just too much input for
your brain to actually process in real
time so most of what it's doing is uh
kind of creating a construct and then
painting a picture of what it is and
then it looks for changes in that
construct wait so Sean this tells me
that if the brain can't complete the
picture it'll make stuff up to fill out
the picture absolutely that's why there
are so many black men in prison right
now
that's one example I was going to say
optical illusions but sure yes racial
incarceration uh inequalities that's
another one yes this is the philosophy
part of the answer which is that there
is there's a real world out there I mean
there there is objective physical
reality but there's also the picture the
image the model of the world that our
brain puts together and they're related
but they're not the same and our brain
is doing a lot of work to take all the
many sense inputs that it has and sew
them together into cohere in picture
yeah and a clever a clever optical
illusion will hijack that ability and
make you think something that is not
very far from true as being true very
but it doesn't quite make sense yeah
yeah all right we've got time from one
last question chuck oh my God this is
over already I know right right yes we
got to do this again this is fantastic I
think he's got other stuff to do you
know he's working on books you know the
man writes books Okay now what's his
latest book you just wrote um on right
now during this episode yeah I'm almost
done
[Laughter]
oh that's excellent wait you've got to
book the biggest ideas in the universe
volume one and you're working on volume
two and this is a physics book where you
you got equations in there and you and
you are you are not apologetic about it
no I mean we don't assume that you know
any math we teach you the math so I
teach a calculus and what have you know
just in case you miss calculus you know
in your school it's in the first couple
of pages right a couple chapters but yes
and then you move on and you learn
tensors and differential geometry and uh
Einstein's equation for general
relativity and this is for the public
you just want to boost the Public's math
literacy a bit I and their self-esteem I
love the public I want them to feel like
they can get they can get this stuff
into their heads it's not so hard really
I love what you said to us Offline that
when you were 16 you wished someone had
written A Book Like This
for you to consume at that time of your
life the quantum mechanics and Quantum
field Theory and particles and
symmetries and Gage Theory had you had
such a book imagine how much smarter you
would be
yeah
it's all out by now
I let one last quick question go okay
this is uh Hamed who says this hi Star
Talk uh this is Hamed from uh Montreal
Canada my question are we still Chasing
the Dream of a unified theory of physics
or is that just a dead end should never
be achieved
love it Sean still chasing it because
there is the universe the universe is
telling us what it does it's just up for
us to think up to us to figure it out so
Sean it's a philosophical bias that you
presume everything can be explained
under one field equation and everything
derived that's a isn't that a bias maybe
the universe is fractured in this way
with multiple forces that can't talk to
one another yeah that's completely fine
I I did not say it was just going to be
one equation I was just about to say it
might be a terrible mess we don't have
any right to say that the final theory
of the whole universe will be simple or
elegant or easily understandable by us
but we can shoot for it we can try and
we can give it our best shot and see
what happens that's what we're trying to
do because we got bad history there in
astronomy where Kepler has he's a
mathematician and he's he knows that
geometry is beautiful and perfect and
there's certain number of platonic
solids kids there's like the cube and
the pyramid and the dodecahedron and he
thinks that relates to the orbits of the
planet and he embeds one in the other he
is philosophically driven with some idea
that the universe is beautiful and
perfect and he spent 15 years wasting
his time until he threw it all I said no
planets just have weird elliptical
orbits and sure enough that's the answer
so we we've had to be we've been through
this in my field uh John I'm just
telling you Hill's artist Kepler I'd be
very very happy okay
yeah
all right we got to call it Chris there
Sean it's been a delight to see you
again and chat with you and Chuck always
good to have you man always a pleasure
Neil deGrasse Tyson here you're a
personal astrophysicist I'm beating you
to keep looking
[Applause]
[Music]